this is a production of Cornell
University as always we wanted to
recognize everybody who's helped with
these webinar series together
GCS a a new york new chapter here
suzanne miss the chapter administrators
helped us out putting together all the
guests we've had over the course the
last three weeks
so today's are the last and the
three-part installment here we're gonna
have ian andrew sorry and i put an extra
s on there Ian Andrew I mean Andrew golf
design and also a writer talking to us
today about what we can get away with in
terms of golf course design and again
quick shout out to the partners and the
sponsors again making this webinar
available so platinum sponsors Andre and
Sun first turf and ornamental grassland
and Harold's gold sponsors Finch turf
BASF on beragon technologies and MTE
and then our silver sponsors as well
Syngenta Ewing nutrient solutions turf
and soil diagnostic we were golf and
turf and dry jet so we'll start with
today is this the usual format we'll get
started with dr. Frank Rossi Frank give
us a little rundown and what we've got
the last week growing season wise and
then we'll get into introducing our
guests sure thing Carl and again thanks
to everybody for joining us and we'll
remind you again about surveys we want
you to fill out we have those available
in the chat Carl's going to give you a
link to the survey we're trying to
determine you know how much this is
worth doing how much you like it what
parts you like don't like and we've been
so thrilled to partner with the GSA and
why just a very exciting time to get the
whole thing kicked off so our golf
course superintendent you know I spend
probably more time looking at Twitter
than I should these days I just love
this picture that a superintendent took
on the beach at about 3:30 in the
morning when basically the only people
awake or golf course superintendents I
think trying to get to the golf course
to work and out through the sky you
could see the various planets and you
know though everything is continuing to
around no matter how hectic sometimes
things tend tend to be and feel like
they can be Brian diagonal put out a
nice little tweet that I just loved you
know everybody who didn't listen to us
about not fertilizing is now going to
see what what what what they have what
wrath they will incur from any
application of fertilizer that was made
maybe prematurely now you may be happy
with all the car traffic but you know
should I go out should I not and and
this is an example and since we got into
lawn mowers everybody started tweeting
these great old-fashioned lawn mowers
this is the Indian motorcycle company
look at the hood ornament on a lawn
mower you got a love you got a love
grass guys alright so Golf is open just
about everywhere it looks like except
Maryland Vermont New Hampshire and
Massachusetts California's got some
restrictions some people are open some
people aren't this is a again a full
dynamic process but I think listen as we
as an industry become comfortable with
the process and set procedures in place
I think everybody's saying golf can
benefit in some strange way from this
whole thing because of the nature of the
way it happens now we may be sorry about
this but you know carts are coming out
right are you gonna increase your cart
fleet are they allowed can they be clean
this was a little discussion I had with
some of the leadership of the New York
State Golf Foundation
Kemba Noi and play called Blake
Halderman ass off was on the
conversation and talking about how
you're gonna clean them are you gonna
let them Drent them this is another
aspect of a golf operation that
obviously you know if you'd normally
have 40 and you're only gonna do one are
you gonna put that Plexiglas thing or
maybe the caddies gonna drive it and
people are gonna walk and just come and
get their clubs
I think arts are gonna be as we've
realized a big part of what the revenue
stream is in golf and I don't see us
giving it up easily
even if golfers start to enjoy walking
again this is a big revenue sir
for us all right as we get out there and
work so thrilled to have our colleagues
at Rutgers University and and the
Diagnostic Clinic that Rich Buckley runs
out of that second bedroom at least
currently and has a colleague Meredith
Melendez that wrote a nice little beast
about hey if you're gonna make
sanitation stuff be careful about if
you're gonna use bleach don't start
spraying bleach all over yourself here's
how you dilute it let's be smart about
these things and there's lots of
resources for how to do it smartly
alright let's talk about my favorite
part the growing season this is what it
was like in the beginning of April and
you can see it was starting to warm and
last week we said we were cooled off and
a few warm days begins to drive soil
temperatures right so look at how the
soil temperatures have risen well into
the 60s and may even be more
specifically if you're managing this so
looking at this at your own place and
just a reminder right these are a couple
of our soil temperature triggers well
established disease management protocol
that that if you feel you've had a
consistent problem with these things of
course we've got this wonderful resource
that was initiated by paul van celli and
now passed on to munch aw clark
koch and a whole collection of young
pathologists that give us really good
information this should be on your
desktop what about good degree days
again last week you could see most of us
were about two weeks or twenty-one days
behind throughout much of upstate New
York you could see even in the
metropolitan New York area you were
anywhere from a week to two weeks behind
normal and this is what it looks like
for the this past coming week you can
see that we're starting to gain momentum
as of Monday we were getting closer to
normal
however it still looks like growing
degree day accumulation base 50 growing
degree to accumulation will be in the
single digits for much of the Northeast
region so again it's a very slow creep
to the growing season on the green cast
Syngenta website that you've got to sign
up and go through the process of getting
Albert Culp and Hoffer I thought made a
pretty bold statement recently saying
listen if you make multiple adult
applications this year that was your
best chance of reducing numbers however
that also leads you down the path of
insecticide resistance so I'll just
remind you all maybe this is a good year
for relying on larvicides and some
really good information on the way to
target those larva sites and scout for
them and I've been fortunate to be
associated with the Bethpage State Park
guys Andy Wilson Mike Hadley Vinny and
everyone else out there that does the
scouting and keeps track of when to
target the application getting it down
to a single or one or two applications a
year complete all right Tommy Witt
posted a picture about his high rate PGR
application on his Bank grass fairways
in Chicago you can see the kind of look
he's getting Paul Koch mentioned the
other day about the reddening you might
see sometimes as a result of a PG r
application when you get some frost for
those of us up for those of us upstate
who have made some PGR applications
already you might see some stunting and
some damage as the temperatures are
getting cooler now as we enter into the
conversation I'm going to pass it to my
colleague Carl scam NT to introduce our
guest for today I don't really need to
take any questions Carl I'll pass it on
to you here's a really nice tweet from
Steve Spatafore right how does it take
more or less time to mow these fairways
in these different directions and boy
did this tweet get a lot of interest but
nowhere near the interest that good old
Cornell alum Tom Kaplan alignment for
the Cornell football team golf course
superintendent down on Long Island made
a comment hyperbolic he admitted about
the great conditions when you don't have
to take care of a bunker so much Carl so
I'm gonna shut up now and really looking
forward to the conversation that will
ensue with regard to this so let me pass
it to you Carl and introduce our guest
for today yes so I think that's a great
transition Frank we're talking about our
top of today's how little can you get
away with and of course I guess is Union
drew a golf course architect Frank
got a photo in the background there one
of his projects Laval I think that was
done in conjunction with my queer isn't
it isn't that right it's correct and
also it's not for a lefty it's a
left-handed golf course I'm left-handed
I know have the players in Canada
left-handed that's right and and you
know a lot of Canadian audience may
recognize Ian's maybe stand quite a bit
bit of work up there st. George's
notably and and also has just released a
book actually on Stanley Thompson the
Canadian architect - who built st.
George's so if you if you're interested
in that if you're out of Stan Lee
Thompson course I'd really recommend
maybe doing that so I know you won't
promote yourself Ian but I'm gonna do it
for you Andrew golf calm that's where
you can can kind of look at all Andrews
work Ian's work excuse me so with that
in I'll let you go ahead and share your
screen and really excited to hear today
about you know kind of a minimalist
aspects of golf architecture data can
still provide a fun playing experience
and interesting planets then it's so uh
take it away thank you so one of the
thing
that was interesting for me was when we
entered into this it gave me an
opportunity to pivot and the question
ended up being how much could we what
could we get away with if we do if we
actually had to change the game a little
bit I thought it was an interesting
topic so my cover slide happens to be
for people who have seen it in rural
country club in 1951 and what's most
interesting for me is at the time they
still had fescue rough but it also shows
a little bit of our expectations where
we're lower and you know this does bring
the whole question of can we get away
with a little less so one of the things
I wanted to point out is if we got back
to the basics of the game this is
essentially what it looks like in this
case there are no T's it's just fairways
and greens it's a little public facility
that I took my kids out to play to try
it reminds us that the games actually a
little simpler than we always expect it
to be but I think what's most important
is I talk about you know what can we do
to if we had to bring the game backwards
a little bit and make the game simpler
what could we do so the obvious thing is
bunkers and you know the first argument
against it is bunkers create strategy
and one of the things I wanted to point
out was we actually need a lot less than
people think
so I thought this would be kind of fun
just to pick particular golf hole and
look at it so this is the 18th of
Bethpage which a lot of people are
familiar with and the 18th the Bethpage
to me is one of the most overdone holes
that I know of so I thought it would be
a fun one to pick on a concept that I
like to mention is so dumb that Lucas
Glover hit a six iron off the tee in the
US Open just to avoid all the trouble
because there was no percentages in it
so this is just to point out that the
exact same strategy can be accomplished
with 60% less sand and that's part of
the reduction sometimes could be in
surface area but the other end of it is
if you start to look at what's essential
if you look at these three bunkers they
actually accomplish the same question
as the original architecture and now
we're down to 80 percent less sand and
because there's far less bunkers it
actually invites more aggressive play
because it's less obvious and again if
we start to look at the idea of risk and
reward
creating a carry angle on the left-hand
side opening things up on the right
which by the way would open things up
for playability you're now asked whether
you want to take on the trouble to open
up a much an easier approach or play
wide and then have to hit a better shot
in and this is more of risk reward
strategy as opposed to a penal point of
view and if you notice we're now down to
four bunkers and 85% of the sand well if
we combine those bunkers we're now down
to two we're still asking a strategic
question that hole still holds up really
well there's a lot more risk/reward
intent it's a lot more playable because
now they've got fairway running up to
the green and you can play to a safer
side and because if you mowed down the
bank on the right-hand side and you cut
it tight that would have meat more
effective than a bunker on that
right-hand side this is essentially all
you need for this particular hole so
what I wanted to make really crystal
clear for everybody is we always assume
bunkers to find strategy for a golf
course and they're an essential element
they are important because they have a
visual impact but you don't need quite
as much as you you think you do and
that's one of the things is the biggest
win is always in the bunker so a good
example just to kind of drive that home
is Augusta National's started with 29
bunkers it has 44 and a vast majority of
those are doubled up and tripled up
bunkers they're just fairway bunkers
that the fazio groups been adding
recently it still didn't have a lot of
bunkers up until about 20 years ago but
you don't need much to create strategy
what you've got some alternatives that
can create strategy whether it's just
blowing a lot of short areas or fair or
green contours but bunkers are less
essential than most people think
one of the things
interesting is if you watch I had the
opportunity to go around we're looking
at Laval I went around with my career
and I've been around Augusta and that's
actually Mike it was just the two of us
there what plays a major role in where
they play their positional shots - is
this the slopes of the Greens that the
bunkers are not as important to them
because they're not really worried about
getting up and down from them but
they're always looking at green slopes
and then how to attack the hole using
those green slopes so the Greens
actually are the primary source of
strategy for a golf ball so Riviera the
10th is probably the best example I can
possibly provide for you and if you
anybody who's ever been there you're
drawn to try and take a direct line at
the green and the funny part about it is
essentially that's the worst direction
you can choose to go if you end up on
line with the green because the green
runs away from play
you really can't hit the green with a
pitch shot it's too difficult to shot
and even the pros have a lot of trouble
making that shot but the further left
the further you get away from the
bunkering the more ideal the approach is
and funny enough the the left rough as
far over as you could possibly go with a
full swing is actually the way that the
pros who choose to lay out play for this
hole so essentially the green strategy
or the green surface itself is really
the defining strategy of this golf hole
and it's the one that means it
determines where you want to be and how
you want to approach things and actually
the bunkers are just there to fool you
so as I said bunkers are less important
than you think so
what you're trying to do is you're
trying to take the bunkers that you have
if you're looking to make things a
little bit more efficient is try to make
the matter more so the definition of a
great bunker is one that you have to
flirt with the score better so this is
the six that world Melbourne and if you
play tight to the fairway bunkers on the
right hand side which is the longest
carry if you could make the carry you
you actually get a pretty good look at
the glean and the green feeds towards
you so you're well rewarded for taking
that risk
because of the way the slopes work at
the hole you can play around the bunker
is you can take the short carry but now
you've got to face the most the most
diabolical bunker of all is the front
left which is about 10 to 12 feet deep
and everything runs down to that bottom
and it's a very intimidating bunker shot
from down in there so what you try to do
is you try to simplify it that you need
to flirt with something in order to
score and that's sort of how you pare
back your bunkers every every other
bunker is less relevant than those
bunkers so if you're trying to get
yourself down to basic strategies you're
trying to get yourself down to that so
how do you sell this to a membership the
front the right side image is the
beginning point with four bunkers the
only bunker that really mattered was the
inside left the bottom is a Photoshop
illustration everybody's pretty good at
Photoshop nowadays but it's showing the
what it could look like afterwards and
if you look at that image or you look at
the final results of it this is maple
downs you can see that the false front
the the runoff areas essentially provide
the same thing what they do is they
repeal golf shots so what we're looking
at is the maintenance is reduced to a
single bunker instead of four bunkers
and now you're asking shortgrass to do a
lot of the other let's call it defense
to the hole and and this is a way of
simplifying things the reason I bring up
this slide is I did this product I did
the planning for this project in 208 209
and that was when we went through the
financial crisis the financial crisis
for us in southern Ontario was
devastating and what it did is it
brought up the question of economic
sustainability in golf and I think
that's about where we're going to go
again post crisis now and that's why I
bring this up and that's why I thought
staring this presentation towards that
sort of talks about where we might or
probably will end up going this is just
an overall plan for the golf course and
essentially we paired everything from
fifty six down to thirty nine bunkers
so pare down the maintenance the style
of maintenance and that was part of what
we did we were actually in a green
rebuilding program but that was part of
what we did at the same time was we just
got everything down to what we thought
was essential this is a picture of one
of the holes you can see by the red
lines that essentially the two bunkers
are there I'd argue you could remove the
first one but you can see the shape of
an s-shaped fairway that is a great way
of creating risk of reward but there
could be bunkers on the right-hand side
this hole used to have six bunkers there
could be fairly bunkers on the
right-hand side but they're not really
necessary being out of position is just
as much a hindrance to a player scoring
so essentially what you're saying is
where you want to be is where all the
trouble is and if you don't take on the
trouble then you've got to take on
trouble in the next shot and that's
that's sort of the this is the basic
risk of reward scenario and if you think
about this idea this probably does
answer what's necessary and what's not
necessary your golf course so here's a
good example this happens to be Craig
burn the outside bunkers on this hole
are not necessary if you hit the ball
through you're in the rough penalty
number one you're out of position
penalty number two and you don't have a
great look at that green site because
you're now at an off angle penalty
number three that's as that works just
as well as actually having bunkers out
there in fact you could argue that the
bunkers actually contain the shots from
getting further away and put the players
in a better position and an elite player
will actually be able to hit a decent
shot out of that with some spin because
they can spin the ball out of the
bunkers particularly when the bunker lie
is flat so being out of position is
enough you don't have to contain
everything you don't have to penalize
everything by the way the target bunkers
were not part of the Golden Age not part
of the teens 20s and 30s there was
something that was added to the game in
modern times mainly to provide
definition they actually don't really
have that much strategic relevance to
the game whatsoever so this is probably
my greatest pet peeve
Bunker's that are done strategist Wow
strategic are done specifically for
aesthetics I think this is the sort of
thing that should be the first removal
is a getting rid of if this was a waste
area I wouldn't have as big a problem
with it but the fact that it's got high
faces and and details to it and and in
this case you could see it's all being
edge it's complete waste of time to me
so this is what I think the game will
will throw away very quickly if push
comes to shove so what I wanted to make
really clear to to all of you is the
area in the foreground the short grass
particularly with a sharp slope is every
bit as much a penalty to an elite player
as that bunker is in behind that happens
to be my Clayton my Clayton was a former
tour player from Australia but we talked
about the fact that the balls all run to
the flat sand and he can spin it and so
he has he feels as confident there as he
does in the hollows and he said with the
hollows one of the things he struggles
with is sometimes you'll get a really
tight lie and he's not sure where to use
the green and he said he'd actually
rather be in the bunkers for the most
part because they put him in much better
position and that gives you sort of an
idea that short grass is an alternative
particularly the way we maintain it in
current times as tight as we maintain it
so one of the things that I like
architectural a with short grass this is
Levasseur lilac is that once a player
misses particularly a good player
there's no ring of rough at the back to
contain them so once they miss either
saw it to the side or long which is more
common with the elite player and a
higher handicap has a tendency to miss
short once the ball has missed rather
than just sitting in the ring where they
play a little bump and run back make an
easy par now all of a sudden the ball
runs and goes so the beauty is that now
they have a much more difficult recovery
shot and this is why when we put these
areas in the lot of times you get
resistance because they say you're gonna
make the game easier but it actually
starts to make it harder for the elite
player one of the examples I love to use
is in the front two bunkers particularly
on the right you're in great shape to
get up and down at Shinnecock zone 11th
hall the side bunkers are much worse
because you've got to deal with that
severe green slope but the short grass
over the back which looks like an easy
recovery is actually the most is
probably the most impossible shot I've
ever seen because there is no way to
stop the ball and essentially it's going
to run off the front usually back into
the bunkers and it's a good example
where often short grass is actually a
tougher element to deal with but it's
one that I find committees don't
understand that the fact that it's much
heart and that's maybe one of the
beauties for us as architects it's much
harder than it looks
whereas bunkers look hard and sometimes
are easier than they initially appear so
the beauty of chipping areas for golf is
they provide option of flop shot chip or
a putt the elite player has a tendency
to always want to use their wedge
because I could some full control but
the tighter the lie the harder the shot
it is for them and we all know for the
high handicaps they love these options
because they play to their favorite shot
most of them putt a lot my father's in
his 90s he plays bump-and-run shots
still and it allows him to show his
creativity but the beauty is the short
grass areas they maintain the difficulty
for the elite player but they are the
only thing that levels the playing field
for the higher handicap and the beauty
of it is for all of us talking today
it's far easier to maintain than a
bunker so if you think about it if you
have say 50 or 60 bunkers and you end up
with 20 chipping areas instead and 40
bunkers for argument's sake you're not
dealing with washouts you're not dealing
with a lot of problems yes there's some
increased maintenance to do with the
fact you're gonna have to spray and cut
these areas but it takes away the the
damage control that you have to do and I
do find that the playability and the
fact that you don't have to go and main
rebuild these or do major works to them
on a regular basis like you do with the
bunkers because bonk
do have a shelf life this is a far
easier element to deal with and I think
this is where golf's gonna go I think
the chipping areas are going to increase
in use and I think the bunkers are gonna
decrease over time so Pinehurst to me is
the greatest example of explaining to a
good player or a great player why this
works
tough as nails in the US Open and yet
it's a golf course you can't lose the
ball and I do find high handicaps can
play to their handicap here and I've yet
to play with a really really top-notch
player or complaint of their handicap in
this golf course particularly when it's
a little bit firm and dry so it shows
you that the chipping areas have sort of
a double effect it it can hurt I mean
I've been and I've made my triple bogeys
out here too but the other thing is the
recovery shots I get to play tots most
comfortable a lot of times I can get up
and down because I'm actually pretty
good with a bump and run bunker is there
an element that are sort of absolute a
great player with a good bunker game
it's not a big deal particularly how you
guys maintain them nowadays for a high
handicapper who's not got any bunker
game they can be devastating to her
round so I wanted to show you some
alternatives that I think could come
into play so this is Royal Adelaide you
can see the ridge between the fairway
and the green so this is a view from the
other side I happen to think this is one
of the best holes in all of golf what I
love about this hole is it's definitely
reachable with a driver and there's
nothing worse than hitting your ball
just left because it still cut his
fairway and trying to find this this
green is almost impossible with a pitch
less than a full Club because the green
actually runs towards the back but this
sort of idea there's not a single bunker
on it should be something we should see
regularly in golf but we see very few
examples of this and I think this is
sort of one of these details that could
really make a comeback here's an example
of Pete Dye doing something similar this
is simply 2 feet bars 2 feet sorry
yeah it's 2 feet on the left edge and
it's three and a half to four feet by
those stairs
there's fairway just on the other side
of that Bank and there's fair
running to that Bank it's just simply a
a 45-degree angle of bluegrass it's the
golf club in New Albany Oh Ohio but this
has an incredible impact on this hole
and yet it's such a simple feature and
it's not a long Bank to have to maintain
I do see going forward that some of
these ideas will finally start to make a
comeback some of these simpler easier to
maintain ideas are actually pretty
strong it's just we we seem to get sort
of caught up in the idea of bunkering
always rather than looking for something
that's a little more creative and clever
like this great example of glens falls
nowadays I see these this Bank will be
covered in bunkers this hole does not
need bunkers it does have one on the
outside right but the bank once you miss
that green it's it's bounding down and
the other end of it is the result of a
grass bank is a little bit more
arbitrary which that is something we do
need to return the golf I'd aussi argue
I wish bunkers were less well maintained
as an architect because I think the
result should be a little bit more
arbitrary and then they'd have more
strategic values so this is a great
example of if this had bunkers this hole
wouldn't be that difficult the fact that
the green actually falls away this is
the third at Augusta the Green falls
away and yet the front bank is cut short
makes this the hardest hole in the golf
course according to Mike when we were
talking about it it's so hard to hit
that delicate shot in but because the
ball will back up and go 25 to 30 feet
away from that bank and that shot being
a half wedge pit shot which is probably
the least comfortable shot for even an
elite player these are the sort of
features that easier to just simply mow
that is fairway not deal with a bunker
not deal with 45-degree bluegrass banks
this is more impactful than actually a
bunker or or a bunker and bank would be
so I'd like to see these features come
back and I think if we look at some of
these we don't necessarily need those
super deep
steep fronting bunkers where sometimes
we could turn these into sharp fairways
where the ball is running back and
attack should actually have a bigger
impact if you're trying to play defense
one thing to keep in mind is on a
playability and if you do this you you
have to make sure that the higher a knee
caps have somewhere to bail and that's
as an architect important to sometimes
not sort of ramp things up to a point
where you let people literally will end
up picking up and going on to the next
hole so bunkers themselves by number you
could probably I find most courses I've
been to I could probably take a third of
the bunkers comfortably and the next
part is Bunker maintenance itself I
think that's where we're going to need
to go this is Penn field one of the
things with Penn field was we did a
major bunker reduction got them to be
efficient but we also created a bank to
try and reduce the maintenance I'm gonna
make the point of as an architect I
believe you if you have nothing to
maintain that's difficult and your golf
course is usually pretty dull what I try
to do is just limit it to something like
this where the the bank matters and then
try to ease off the rest of the
maintenance that's kind of my viewpoint
I do believe you should have little
things to deal with because that's what
creates the architectural interest so
this is st. George's these are pretty
high faces the way it's dealt with is
detailing and I think you can have high
faces you just have to detail them out
the best way I can put it is your
expenses upfront if you spend the money
upfront which yes it's very expensive
and that's why you try to take a bunker
reduction if you're gonna go with high
faces and you try to limit how much of
the face you're gonna show up this is
historically important so we kept all
the original faces but you must detail
it to avoid washout sand erosion
we'd had a five inch rain event
place in the middle of this bunker
project this is a picture from that
event that's actually the on-ramp the
bunkers did not wash out at all so if
you detail it you can actually take away
that maintenance but again there's a
massive expense upfront if that's the
route you're gonna go otherwise I would
say for the most part if we were if I
was look sort forward thinking and and
things have changed
bringing the grass to the floor is one
of the most important things what it
does is obviously starts to remove
washouts by the way the way we detailed
this is if you put an interceptor around
the base of the grass bank that also
deals with the sort of that initial
flush you can get at the edge because of
what it does is it just draws the water
instantly in and so we had didn't see
any wash outs by adding that detail but
the other end of this is the same sand
volume too if you've got no high san
faces you're limiting the bunker to the
area that it needs to be to defend or
define whatever you're trying to do with
it again this is Park Club and Buffalo
this is historically accurate so that's
why the bunker winds its way around the
8th grade this is grass face but this
does nothing teas made and shimazo have
five faces
I would jokingly say if this is where
your architect suggests then you get a
new architect old-school methods are a
way of dealing with things I started
working with a place called look at a
point discovered that it's built on
gravel and they did clay lining and that
was where I learned that back in the 20s
they did a lot of clay lining sort of
understood that that was what that layer
was that I kept finding it some of the
bunker work so here's a good example
where we're clay lining bunkers and by
the way it can be organic clay over
experimenting with time with just having
trouble finding clay in Montreal because
Montreal is all shale underneath you
have to line your bunkers but this is a
way of dealing with things it's a lot
cheaper at the time we were doing this
for about five hundred dollars a bunker
and it gives you a lookout point we're
done in 22 and they still have no lock
problems what we do a lot of around
Buffalo area and part of its budget
related part of it is just lack of
native materials is grass line and grass
lining lasts a shorter time but if
you've got a tight budget it's certainly
an answer and it does buy you extra time
because it takes a while for that
organic layer to break down finally
before the stone starts to push through
so this is an alternative there are
cheaper alternatives the things and if
you're on a tight budget what I want to
point out is essentially erosion is the
enemy doing nothing means you're one bad
washout from rebuilding again once this
happens your bunkers are actually done
it's just a matter of when and I've seen
this happen at a project in Nova Scotia
not one I had anything to do with where
when I would see a new golf course and
there one of the bunkers where all the
water ran across the green and through
and all the shale underneath was exposed
and that bunker was done that and it was
not even a year old and the worst part
was that men they had to strip out the
whole thing to replace the sand every
time that happens they're running the
same thing and every bumper needs a
detail at the edge so one of the best
pieces of advice I can give you is
you're if you've got a soil edge
essentially that's erosion it's
organized erosion but it's erosion and
your bunker life span is essentially ten
years max if you're edging but if you're
edging bunkers because essentially they
break down and they wash out too easily
and you get contamination and you get
contamination your drains so the most
important thing is to come up with a
detail you should never be edging
lunker's with soil edges there's a this
happens to castle Stewart during the
build in that's actually glance on the
left-hand side they do a lot of bunkers
he builds he does the riveted edges
which you can see on the very left hand
side of the boys and on the right hand
side that is what's called chunking
which is a
native grasses pacted and that also is
an edge and that's essentially what
you're trying to deal with chunking but
this is a national golf club in Toronto
just growing over the edges what he does
is undercutting there which you remove
soil in and curl the the grass in and
and pin it in place
soils allow for that they're doing that
gives you an edge but you need to come
up with a with an edge that's not soil
and that will double the length of your
lifespan if you never have any exposed
soil and if you have a line or
underneath and I think in today's day
and age where we can't afford to do much
and I think going forward economically
we're going to struggle you need an edge
another if if the environment allows for
it fescue faces this is Plymouth Country
Club I work with in Massachusetts what
they do is they cut these sometimes they
don't cut them other times but all the
banks are fescue faces and that's how
they limit the amount of maintenance
because they've got a small crew and a
small budget and anytime you can do this
they do unfortunately particularly in
south facing slopes dry out you may have
to do work one of the ways to deal with
that is if you actually have a fescue
nursery you can replace your own sod in
a regular basis so other ideas to reduce
maintenance this is pepper pike in
Cleveland this was a forest this is now
long grasses the idea of trying not to
maintain areas as much as possible the
trick to this wrong slide the trick to
this is you need to understand where
people are not very often and think of
this more as an accent so one of the
fascinating things for me is I've always
looked at one of the reductions is
reducing the height of cut of grains so
I went to a presentation and I for life
me I can't remember who it was and this
is something I forgot to look up
yesterday but they did studies where
they varied the heights of greens over a
period of time and they used a
membership survey where all the members
at all
levels of play were surveyed and they
discovered that the happiest that the
entire membership was was actually
between nine and a half and ten and a
half it wasn't 11 or 12 there's no
question the elite players are always
looking and funny enough the 15 handicap
who's actually really in 18 they're
looking for those high green speeds but
the majority of players actually don't
want something that's excessive and they
use this technique to try and sort of
win the war on having excessive green
speeds because we all know if we can
back off a foot it makes a tremendous
amount of difference on what we have to
spend to keep that condition but also
increases the amount of pin and reduces
the amount of wear so that's a huge
difference T's so I'm gonna run contrary
to the the school of thought that's
going on right now I think we're
building too many tees I think we're
we've lost our minds so I think we're
overthinking this I think if we went to
more hybrid teas where we had a long tea
at middle tea and a front tea and then
buried that up to make up for the
difference in between those those teas
we're actually in a much better place I
think the amount of intensive
maintenance of teas doesn't make up for
the reduction the potential reduction in
fairway that sometimes takes place I
think we've got to get back to just a
few teas I think we've lost our minds
and I by the way I think we also need to
just unless you're an elite club holding
elite vents I think we need to get away
from having the excessively long teas
because essentially their turf nurseries
and there's no point in having them for
the most part I'm I think we've got to
get back to servicing the majority and
most cases but that that's sort of
particularly in public golf more so than
private golf I think that becomes a
little more difficult so raising the
height of fairways one of the fun parts
about that is if we all raised our
heights of fairway I know there's some
turf reasons for not one
to do it but one of the things because
most of the players sweep and don't
pinch the ball 90% of players be far
more comfortable and the interesting
thing is it would actually put more
pressure on an elite player because now
they've got a judge how that ball is
going to fly I don't think this is an
easy one to win the other thing is
removing the step cut so if we remove
the step cut we removed need for a mower
we also remove about five hours a week
on that time to maintain that one area
and the way you remove the step cut is
you if you think about it if we can
raise our fairways and lower our rough
we don't need that because the
transition is not that great and what
we're all fighting with is is our
rougher high our fairway is so low that
the transition is so overwhelming but if
we would actually lower our rough
Heights raise our fairway heights we
would actually get away from this step
cut and I our Kotak I find the step cut
to be one of the worst features that
have ever emerged and I actually don't
like it architectural a as well and I
spend a lot of time trying to well I
don't counsel I push clubs trying to
eliminate it so one of my big things is
I wish we could return to seasonality
I'm old enough that I remember playing
most of my golf with ruffs that went
Brown and having to accommodate the fact
that the ball now didn't stop once it
got into the rough and it would roll out
into the trees I work with Quogue field
clubs in Long Island and they definitely
embrace seasonality this is a green
version of that golf course by the way I
wish we would allow extremes to take
place
this is Marais and Scotland this is what
happens once we get to drought in an
ideal world we would actually embrace
this and get back to it it would save us
a lot of money and a lot of effort and
essentially what that comes down to is I
if what I wish we would do is we would
stop fertilizing and watering ruffs I
always love the Australians who question
our sanity by saying they maintain
exactly where the player is supposed to
be so they maintain tees fairways and
greens and they don't maintain where
they should
be so what they do is they do minimal
maintenance beyond so if they've got
rough they don't water fertilize it but
what they'll do is they'll they may do a
little bit of mowing just to control it
or they may do some control with those
areas but essentially they ignore it and
that's their view that the the game is
supposed to be a lot more sporty than
our North American view where you expect
a good line in the rough in a perfect
world I wish I could sort of encourage
that that everything should be more
arbitrary once you get outside of the
bounds of the fairways the interesting
thing about Quogue field club is there's
no irrigation in the rough it's actually
a central row irrigation system and
sorry I'll go back on that so one of the
things that was fascinating about it I
think I actually come to it and two
slides from now is we're doing they're
sorry they are doing a new irrigation
system and the new irrigation system
will remain single row with just a
little bit more controls around the
greens and that's it so new arrogation
systems one of the biggest problems I've
run into with renovations as new
irrigation systems are just they simply
start at two million or more I look at
all the clubs I work with I know the
financial situation of most of them and
they can't they they're struggling to
deal with the debt that they currently
have whether it's clubhouse related or
whether it's renovation related and
adding another two and a half million
dollars to their to their borrowing
costs is going to be something that
they're going to struggle to overcome as
I said you don't have to be wall-to-wall
green and Quogue is going to continue to
embrace that we had that it's
interesting as an architect being asked
to be part of that conversation and I
wish clubs would have that conversation
involving us where we can recommend to
them that it's time to actually allow a
little bit more of the exterior of the
golf balls to just be a little bit more
natural a little a little more
uncontrolled that would be good for the
game so I had talked about minimizing
maintained area I do think in a place
like Pinehurst this works really well
I'm not so sure this works in upper New
York State where we've got heavier soils
but the idea of just trying to maintain
a little bit less and and figuring that
out I think we have to be very careful
with the use of fescues and particularly
on heavy soils or places where they get
rich get fertility I went through this
with pepper pike our goal is to
establish what's an accent and every
time we get to in play areas we just
simply we may turn those areas into
fescue but we we actively maintain them
and cut them and we're trying to do
experiments with adding sand and trying
to see if we can get some of those areas
then but if we can't get them thin then
we just cut them just avoid native areas
long grass areas and player is if you've
got your members are looking at an
adjacent area like this it's probably
better to just mow these areas a lot
more until you can do something that
controls it and put it this way if
you're pulling weeds and spraying in and
it's becoming more maintenance that
would as main as a rough mowed rough
area then maybe it's time just to start
mowing those areas instead of trying to
maintain a fescue and putting all that
intensive work into it and then I'll
throw in the one thing is with ticks and
everything else you've just got to be
very careful about how far you go with
that so stating the obvious don't plant
trees the one thing that I've spent a
lot of time is explaining the lifetime
maintenance obligations of a tree I I
didn't think about that - mm-hmm
one of the superintendent's mentioned
that awhile ago and I thought that was a
really great observation if we put a
price tag to what a tree's gonna cost us
over the long run it's fascinating to
think that when a tree goes in that
essentially that tree over its lifetime
is going to be a ten thousand dollar
commitment it's mind-blowing to think
that way and so trying to get people to
be a little bit more careful with their
use and species that's the other thing
is understanding certain species are
difficult maintenance and
other species or acceptance let's call
it and then the whole aspect of they
they've ruined playability they damaged
turf and they they create horrible
growing environments and frankly this is
this to me is the worst example of what
golf can devolve to I'd rather fish than
play here so ideal use of trees I've
always used a slide with committees
that's my view of trees I do think they
have a place I do think partland
parkland Golf has a place but I see
parkland golf being fewer trees and if
we could actually start to think like
this we'd have specimen trees weight
foots a great example where they have
specimen trees but essentially if you
get off line it's really easy to get
back and play my best way to explain it
to everybody is if you can't figure out
how to get out of a tree line then
there's too many trees it should be a
very easy opportunity to put the ball
back and play and return to play so the
other thing is we all know I'm stating
the eyes to all of you we'd use less
water less fertility and less
applications if we had less trees and
the interesting thing is I've always
said that the clubs when I'm talking to
them it means more money saved and my
argument has always been that not only
is there more money saved we actually
get better playing conditions in the
long run so quick case study Wheatley
Hills on an island this is the 13th this
was a renovation that was done in very
recent times I was asked to come in and
look at it this is a Deborah Emmett
course and clearly this is not a
different restoration and renovation
what happened was they just this whole
alone they doubled the number of bunkers
and they added the high sand phases that
bunker face on the left is ten feet deep
when you stand in the interior of the
bunker and the bunker face itself is
more than 45 degrees and essentially the
best way to describe it is it was done
with a bunker liner and the liner and
the sand and everything was literally
falling down as soon as it got wet
everything fell to the bottom
so this is having an overview this is
what it looked like in plan that when
you get things back to their simplicity
by the way back to what was originally
there the three bunkers on the left and
again remember I was talking about out
of position if you're on the left you're
out of position you're hitting into the
narrow part of the the green site the
other thing is if you're trying to hit a
little flip wedge in that's you're also
ten feet below the green so bunkers on
the left came out because they
originally weren't there you can see how
many trees have also come out around it
as well if you have a look and then
getting it back to the original
bunkering which was the fairway bunker
was the decision interestingly enough
that is very deep and dead and then the
ridge really matters more on the fairway
and then back to the original two
bunkers and you can sorry you can see
the amount of sand is a lot less than
the bunkering that's above the back
bunker came out and we increased the
green size back to original green so
that's what we took it back to that's
actually the original version of the
hole but you can also start to see the
amount of maintenance that was reduced
at the same time and essentially what
the superintendent's dealing with is
just those banks and what we've tried to
do is get the maintenance down to the
things that matter that sort of set that
line between success and failure that's
what the steep banks do and then the
rest of its all maintainable and that's
essentially a case study and how you do
it so funny enough it's historically
accurate but it's also far more
sustainable so what's holding us back
generally it's the golfers and I think
that's where architects come in we have
to convince the club through having a
conversation about sustainability that
not only involves environments but it
involves economics as well and I do
think all of a sudden economic
sustainability is going to be a
conversation we're going to have so as I
said I think it's time that architects
and architecture takes far more
responsibility and what we build and
what we leave behind and I think we have
an obligation
to make sure that that what we leave for
you or what we promote with a club has
is much more sustainable in the future
and my big argument has always been if I
pare things back to something that works
for the club now in harder times there's
nothing to stop you and I in the club of
adding a few more adding a little bit
more detail over time when it's
appropriate and and that sort of been my
argument that was moved my argument with
maple downs and when things went really
well for them I've reached out to them
and said okay I did say I'd had this
conversation and they came back to me
and said no we're really happy with the
way things work we like this tight
sustainable model and we're gonna stick
with it so Karl that's actually my
presentation that's the whole thing you
know I found myself nodding my head the
whole time I don't know about you Frank
but I think I think Ian's a man every
superintendent's hard after no hearing
about some of these you know aspects you
know reducing Bunker's drug you know
drying out the fairways the seasonality
of that you know eliminating step cuts
things like that I have a question for
you you know I'm kind of on those topics
if I'm a superintendent I'm listening to
this and I'm saying yeah you know I can
really do all of that
but how should I go about talking to my
membership or my greens committee what's
the process they should go through when
they see something like this and say hey
I want to kind of do that what should
their their process be rather than just
trying to sell one of the elements sell
a philosophy first so promote a
philosophy that's that begins with the
idea that the plan conditions are not
going to be reduced they're going to be
different that the architectural
elements maybe maybe things are going to
be changed a little bit that are going
to respect this but talk about the
impact of it so that you know when I'm
up selling this I don't sit there and
say well the great part is we're going
to reduce a golf course by 20 bunkers I
talk about each of the
holls strategically and how they're
gonna play and and what impact the
changes are going to make to the play
for players and so you sell it as a as a
positive not on what it's going to save
for the maintenance or for the club you
sell it on an architectural vision or a
maintenance vision on how it's going to
be better for them and then you throw in
by the way this maintenance vision is
actually going to save a little bit of
money or you never by the way you never
say it's gonna save a little bit of
money you may drop that with a couple of
people but to the membership when you
present as a whole you say we're going
to then be able to work on other details
that we think are far more important
because you never tell them there's
anything whenever they ask I always say
no we're gonna save maintenance in this
we're just going to apply it to other
things that you value more and you have
to you have to phrase your way around
things so that they don't ever think
anything is coming back and hopefully
for the superintendent it means they can
allocate resources much more
appropriately for them so Frank you got
any questions yeah you you um you talked
about well you know if you want to have
an interesting golf course you're just
gonna have to have a couple of tough
parts to maintain thank you for speaking
candidly about that these things are
difficult to maintain things like leaky
hose and and how you spray them if they
need to be sprayed can you talk a little
bit about I mean you know it seems crazy
but is rivetting have you ever looked at
the way to do these faces that that
might make them a little bit better you
mentioned rivetting to kill does it you
know what do you think about trying to
make those what do you do to try to help
the superintendent make those areas
maybe not as painful to manage so I
better explain the rivetting the
rivetting is not a soil rule that they
you would think of in the UK which by
the way those are going away very fast
I've noticed the rivetti is maximum of
five layers
minimum usually about three and what
Gil's doing with that detail is he's
creating a vetted face that grows in and
you allow that grass to actually become
established on the face and so what
happens is you get with that sculpted
leading edge but it's actually it it
what happens is everything roots knits
and you end up with a vertical face
that's that's a maintained edge its tan
it's stable and all he's trying to do is
he's just trying to create that as you
saw in the one picture of st. George's
we did it with topsoil filled burlap
bags and so that's a rich organic so
part of the reason is one of the issues
at st. George's is it's actually a
really sight land a light sandy loam and
what we're trying to do is we're trying
to get an area that retains more
moisture than anywhere else at the
leading edge because any experiment that
was done that detail was actually
established in 2000 when we did the
first restoration anything that we tried
before that with trying to use the
native soils it dried out and it broke
down too easily and what we found was
while we would lose a few bunker edges
that way they actually held up pretty
good so only when we went to do it again
with the Billy Bunker because he and
wanted Billy Bunker because of the the
washout problem that he hadn't he's got
sand phases that are ten feet high but
it's got historical importance so and
it's got a club that's wealthy enough to
actually take care of that so that's why
we did that detail is we needed more
organic at that edge rather than doing
we did actually talk about the rivetti
but we struggle with the fact that the
faces were so steeped or rivetting
actually created a really complicated
detail as we were experimenting if you
can imagine we had some pretty
high-priced talent working with shovels
for a day we trying to figure out a way
of doing it we tried five or six
different ways we came back to the
topsoil filled bags by the way that
burlap rots in about 20-25 days it's
called what about the Billy Bunker you
mentioned it
you know I like how you talk about the
lifetime maintenance obligations the
lifetime costs how long these things you
know will require will live have you
seen enough about Billy Bunker use or at
least that sort of you know permeable
concrete in a pervious surface do you
see that as a long-term solution if
you're going to invest in it so yes so
far with I had some questions on how it
would hold up over the winter and
because we have to clay out west we have
some really harsh winters but there are
some examples in the Midwest in the u.s.
that have a number of tough winters
behind them we just don't to be honest
we don't know over 20 years whether
that's going to make a difference with
it's going to hold up but so far it
seems to so that's always been my
question mark whereas the clay I always
know I deal with really extreme freeze
thaw and go back that's why we use clay
because of that I know it works I know
pretty much every liner doesn't overtime
so I'm not very fond of the cloth or any
material liners bentonite seems to work
better than anything else that's
actually a clay liner for ponds part of
it because it relies in its own weight
and the thing is you can seal it with
with a torch you can actually melt it
together as a sheet
it's like putting down a blanket you
don't need staples but I find anything
that needs anything dependent into place
has become a problem my problem is that
there's no perfect solution I would say
Billy is the best one I've seen my
problem by the way and I will speak
there are other solutions I just have
not worked with them so just so
everybody knows
I would I would ask your peers my
problem with Billy Bunker is the
enormous expense that goes with it and
the permanence so here is my viewpoint
from an architect's point of view that
will be funny I don't believe I can get
it right the first time even when I'm
doing a restoration I'm going to make
mistakes one of the joys of going back
to do st. George's was I did the work in
2000 I got to actually fix my mistakes I
apologize this is gonna big for a while
it's our we have a grandfather clock
so the I got to fix my mistakes but I
made mistakes but if you do Billy Bunker
now to fix a mistake or say say my work
is god-awful and you need another
architect to fix the fact I was a
horrible architect it's actually a lot
to pull the whole thing apart and that's
one of my things that I struggle with I
think Billy Bunker has its place when
you're one when permanence is really
permanence where say say you were the
National Golf Links and it's
historically accurate I'd you want it to
be that way for another hundred years I
think yes definitely because it lasts
forever but I struggle with the idea of
if I do a renovation like two Laval
I'm sure when I'm long gone or they're
tired of that somebody else is gonna do
work if I've done Billy Bunker it's
actually a heck of a lot to deal with it
and then there's a whole question of
because of our laws is there can we
dispose of it so I mean I mean I you
know I think about it this way it's a
big upfront expense it seems to be
working in many places and it better buy
you a lot of years and not having to do
it again in any whatever that iteration
is whether you got to do it because you
know somebody said I didn't like it this
way wanted another way you got to do it
because it failed however you know it
better get me enough years that it that
it makes it worth that investment and a
lot of that is as I've seen it is touted
as reducing the sort of regular
maintenance to out but now I very much
appreciate as we wrap up past the
witching hour Carl in that you were
basically saying do you really need
these things and it was very telling
that you took the 18th at Bethpage
because I know Carl himself has geeked
himself out on the 18th and some of the
changes that they made that resulted in
a different golf hole but having pumped
those bunkers out myself during the 2009
US Open I I could agree with you on
their value as an amenity
not necessarily a necessity so thank you
very much in a joy to have you Karl I'll
pass it back to you yes so again even
really really enjoyed that as nod my
head the whole time we don't have any
questions so I guess what I'll do is
I'll just wrap up real quick I do want
to recognize our sponsors again for all
their support pulling this off so once
again
GCS a and why Big Ups to Suzanne miss
who helped put us uh getting this
organized platinum sponsors again Andre
and Sun first orphan ornamental
grassland
Harold's Finch turf BASF pump irrigation
technologies and MDE or our gold
sponsors and our silver sponsors
Syngenta Ewing turf and soil Diagnostics
nutrient solution Weaver Gulf surface
solutions and dry jet and with that
Frank unless you have any last words I
just want to say thanks to to Ian again
thanks to all our guests I don't know if
Doug sold back from last week or is on
as well but you know this is really fun
to put on and I think and hope it was
pretty educational for everybody
thanks very much Ian thanks to did you
CSA my everybody be safe thank you
everybody and I appreciate appreciate
the opportunity this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at cornell edu